[Music]
straight ahead on Law and crime daily
the Parkland school shooter penalty
phase trial did you ever
learn that Linda was ever fearful in her
own home
yes a closer look at the gunman's
relationship with his adoptive mother
and here from the gunman's Middle School
principal do you know any administrators
at Marjorie Stoneman Douglas Douglas yes
I do
did you have any contact with any of
them when he no he did not I feel very
guilty about it plus when he calmed down
he was extra you could see he really he
really was apologetic about what he did
almost like it was another person that
had done did this defense witness hold
up on the stand and later I am very
sorry for what I did and I have to live
with it every day
and that if I were to get a second
chance I would do everything my power to
try to help others just months after
making this apology the gunman creates
disturbing drawings from his jail cell
long crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everybody to the law and crime
daily I am your host Imran Ansari in for
Brian buckmeyer we begin with this show
with a review of week six in the
Parkland school shooting penalty phase
trial on February 14 2018 a then 19 year
old gunman opened fire at Marjory
Stoneman Douglas High School in Parkland
Florida 17 people were killed and 17
more were injured in October of last
year the gunman pleaded guilty to all
charges that means a Broward County jury
will now decide whether he receives life
in prison or the death penalty this week
marked the second week of the defense's
case as the gunsmen's attorneys largely
focused on his Rocky childhood defense
attorneys have called multiple Witnesses
saying the gunman's biological mother
used drugs and alcohol while pregnant
and that his adoptive mother was not
responsive to his cries for help on
Friday a behavior health case manager
took the stand who worked with the
gunman's family she says his adopted
mother Linda Cruz was scared in her own
home
during the time that you were
providing services to the Cruz family
did you ever
learn that Linda was ever fearful in her
own home
yes
and did you learn that from her from her
and do you know what it was that she was
afraid of
mostly her personal belongings getting
becoming missing
because they do recall her walking
around with her purse all the time
um because she thought that the boys
would take things from her
also on Friday Broward County officials
announced a 29 year old man faces
multiple charges after leaving dead
animals on a memorial for those killed
in the Parkland school shooting
officials say 29 year old Robert
Mondragon is being held without bond on
multiple charges including removing or
disfiguring a tumor Monument between
July 20th and 31st Marjorie Stoneman
Douglas employees found a dead duck
raccoon and possum on top of the
monument one of the animals had been
mutilated investigators say they used
surveillance video to track down
Mondragon who later told them he quote
likes the metal and blood smell that
emit from the dead animal end quote
Broward County officials also say
Mondragon has a disturbing fascination
with school shootings as they found text
messages and internet searches about
school shootings in his history
okay joining us today is my co-host
Terry Austin and criminal defense
attorney Jack Rice
Jack I want to start with you let's
start with that Broward County arrest
for placing dead animals on the Parkland
shooting Memorial is it possible
officials just prevented another school
shooting
yeah it certainly is I mean when we look
at school shootings like this we always
end up seeing outrage sort of an odd
combination of outrage apathy sometimes
and what you really get is you get those
who are copycats that's always the fear
is what you may get are those that are
springing up based upon what they're
seeing from others in fact you can think
about Nicholas Cruz himself even in the
videotapes he is actually having of
himself back in 2018 saying I am going
to become the next school shooter that's
always the fear that you're going to
drive people like somebody else with
mental illness with limited capacity to
actually come out and do something else
that is a very very serious problem in a
case like this and it really highlights
just how important it is to watch this
issue and watch how people respond to it
just like Mondragon did and Terry what
can we take away from the behavioral
health case manager's testimony we know
the defendant's adoptive mother was
scared to be in the home with him but
also resisted getting him better help
well you know that case manager really
was on the stand for quite some time and
she talked about she visited the home at
least once a week at least in the
beginning but she tried to make it seem
as though Zach bullied Nick she tried to
make it seem as though Nick was not as
violent as we know he has been obviously
and she did say that Linda was afraid of
the boys and mainly afraid that they
would steal from her the fact that she
had to carry her purse around and sleep
with it really makes you understand that
she's dealing with some serious issues
she may be overwhelmed and I think the
case manager was also trying to say look
we tried to help her she took some of
our advice but not all of our advice so
they're kind of pointing the finger at
Tiffany bars or rather at Linda Cruz and
they're basically saying she didn't take
all of their advice
thank you Jack and Terry and still ahead
on the law and crime daily jurors here
from the defendant's former neighbor who
has conflicting testimony between direct
and cross-examination but first the
defense Narrows in on the gunman's
emotional and educational shortcomings
hear from the defendant's Middle School
principal
[Music]
okay welcome back and defense attorney's
mood for a mistrial Thursday morning in
the Parkland school shooter death
penalty case arguing over evidence
introducing Nazi symbols
so in essence you've now ruled on the
state's sf202 motion that they filed
after the jury was formed admitting this
Foster goes into evidence so at this
time I need to make the following record
and the defense will be moving from this
trial they cannot complain that they did
not know that swastika could be a part
of this of this case they
whatever decision they made that was
their strategy the point is this the
not able to more dire on this issue that
we are forced to introduce very
inflammatory prejudicial evidence
against our own clients
as this what I would call an
anticipatory mistrial
as to evidence that may or may not come
in on cross-examination or evidence that
you have a choice of whether or not you
can put in or through a witness that you
have a choice as to whether or not you
can call
is disingenuous it's denied your motion
for mistrial is denied
testimony continued through the rest of
the day it ended with a former principal
of West Glades Middle School where the
defendant attended he testified the
shooter was a much more needy kid than
any other he had ever seen
after Nicholas left for Cross Creek were
you aware that he was partially
mainstreamed to Marjorie Stoneman
Douglas
um I may have heard about it I think it
occurred the last year that I was the
principal in 2016 maybe and would you
have supported that decision no I would
not have and why
because his uh
there's no way if a school is 1600 or
having challenges in in maintaining and
assisting the kid a student to be
successful a school of 3000 is going to
be that much more difficult
okay do you know any administrators at
Marjorie Stoneman Douglas yes I do
did you have any contact with any of
them when he no I did not
do you wish you had
I feel very guilty about it
okay let's bring in Terry and Jack Terry
let's break down that motion for a
mistrial earlier in the week did the
defense's argument hold any weight and
did that judge make the right decision I
think the argument held no Wade and I
think the Judge made the right decision
although I think she should have ruled
on that motion earlier basically the
defense got up and said look judge you
abused your discretion it's always bad
when you start off an argument attacking
the judge and basically what they were
trying to claim is that their
constitutional rights were not met and
that they were denied due process they
were denied equal protection they were
denied a fair trial and the judge said
no that's not the case we have to hear
the testimony she heard her say it's an
anticipatory mistrial she thought they
were disingenuous harsh words denied the
motion right thing to do but she should
have done it earlier because she would
have avoided a motion for a mistrial
altogether okay and Jack as for the
Middle School principal's testimony he
saw the gunsmen's emotional and
educational difficulties but he did not
discuss these issues with staff at the
high school could he be liable in any
way
well I think in the end it's likely not
but I think what this is really about
from a defense perspective is this is
what they have been doing for the last
two weeks now is establishing a couple
of things he was a broken kid at two
three four five six all of that was true
and they had a lot of individual
testimony from those who were very up
close and personal who could describe
that that means something but then what
they've also done is they've dovetailed
that with multiple opportunities from
the so-called experts whether they were
intellectual whether or not they were
academic whatever it was where they
failed and in this particular case what
we're really talking about is we're
talking about a middle school principal
who should have stepped in and said you
can't mainstream somebody that that's
this broken in the first place and they
turned around and they did it anyway and
this was one example of a whole bunch of
them so you can turn around and say it
was broken in the first place but
everybody who was in a better position
to do something about it didn't bother
or didn't worry about it or did nothing
and now we turn around and and put it in
the lap of a broken kid a broken young
man and we say it's his fault I mean
come on I think there is some power that
came in with that
thank you Jack and Terry and coming up
on the long crime daily blood painted on
the gunman's jails cell walls and
graphic drawings of the school shooting
what the defendant Drew before his
penalty phase began
plus conflicting testimony on direct and
cross-examination by the gunman's former
neighbor
thank you
foreign
[Music]
case in the penalty phase trial of the
Parkland school shooter included
testimony this week from the defendant's
former neighbor he said he was horrified
by the shooting but testified on direct
and cross that after the incident he
still talked to the shooter in jail
you've um
had conversations with the defendant
while he's been in jail correct he's
called me a few times you consider him
to be a friend don't you I would
consider him to be somebody that was in
my life for a short time who I tried to
give some assistance to and tried to
help
I considered him a friend till the
incident happened then
I I had I couldn't have stronger
feelings of of hatred and animosity I
don't think I've ever disliked anybody
more
and as time went by
I just felt
that yeah he suffered from you know
mental illness that no no normal
rational human being could ever do
anything like this when he speaks to
does he seem coherent and logical he
does
okay let's break this down Jack I'm
going to start with you as a defense
witness how did Paul gold hold up on
direct examination
well let's talk about the direct
examination actually I think he did
quite well because he articulated a
couple of things he he articulated how
Nicholas Cruz would do horrible things
and then all of a sudden shift and
almost with surprise uh realized what it
was that he has done and I think the
benefit to that is what it really showed
was a disassociative state the idea that
he would be shocked himself by what was
actually happening and that was really
really useful I actually thought he came
across his extraordinarily credible when
it came to this issue the the cross was
a little different but but from a direct
perspective I thought they sort of
scored the points they were hoping to
score okay Terry and now on the other
side of that courtroom how did gold hold
up on cross-examination what do you
think the jury made of all the cross and
the testimony Well Jack is absolutely
right that cross-examination was very
different from the direct I do think the
prosecution made some point here he was
trying to show inconsistent agencies
first Paul gold said that Linda had not
gotten the defendant help but he didn't
know that he had gotten him help since
the age of three and on the one hand
Paul gold is saying that you know she's
overprotective and yet he's trying to
say that the kids are starving she
basically is being attacked from every
one of the witnesses that gotten onto
that stand so the worst was the movie
though the fact that they talked on that
telephone about producing a movie and
that wasn't good it showed that he is
biased
thank you Terry and Jack and when we
come back a look inside the mind of the
Parkland school shooter we show you the
disturbing drawings and explicit
writings the gunman made ahead of the
penalty phase trial
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]